perdre. Pour éviter ce scénario,
un couple a décidé de braver les
flammes eux-mêmes pour sauver
leur résidence.
- Wish us luck...
it's not gonna burn!
À un moment donné, c'était
assez noir, puis il était
là-dedans, dans le feu, puis
je me suis dit... je hurlais,
là, je hurlais puis je me
pognais la tête parce que...
t'sais, ma tête, ça sonnait...
Puis j'étais là : s'il vous
plaît, quelqu'un, aidez-moi!
Puis je savais pas s'il était
encore vivant dans le feu, là.
- Geneviève Bujold et
son conjoint, Austin Doyle,
ont encore de la difficulté
à croire ce qu'ils ont vécu
au coeur du brasier qui a réduit
en cendres le village de Lytton.
Pour protéger leur résidence,
le couple a refusé de partir
lorsque l'ordre d'évacuation
a été émis. Ils ont passé
la nuit à combattre les flammes.
GENEVIÈVE BUJOLD, propriétaire
d'une maison à Lytton
- Moi, je "spottais" toutes
les étin... t'sais, tous
les feux qui "startaient" autour
la maison, puis je lui criais,
puis lui venait avec la "hose",
puis il arrosait, puis
s'il était trop occupé, bien,
je pognais une bouteille d'eau,
puis j'allais pogner de l'eau...
sur la "tap", puis j'éteignais
avec mon pied, puis j'avais
des gougounes, je me brûlais.
C'était... c'était juste...
l'enfer, là.
Fingers crossed, man!
Je ravalais mes larmes puis...
j'essayais de pas paniquer.
A helicopter came and dropped
a bomb of water on the house...
- À un moment, l'eau
a fini par manquer.
L'aide est venue du ciel.
- La seule option, pour vrai,
je pense, qui nous a vraiment,
vraiment sauvés, c'est...
quand les hélicoptères nous
ont garroché un "bucket" d'eau
sur la maison... que j'étais sur
le top du toit, puis je criais,
je hurlais, puis à un moment
donné, j'attendais que la fumée
soit comme partie pour
qu'il soit capable de
me voir d'en bas, fait que,
quand il m'a vue, j'ai dit :
s'il vous plaît, là...
- Son souhait a été exaucé,
la maison a été épargnée,
mais tout autour, un paysage
d'horreur s'offrait à eux.
- C'était l'enfer, c'était
comme un film d'horreur, là.
Je marchais, il y avait
des poteaux électriques à terre,
le feu qui en brûle encore...
t'sais, les choses du monde
par terre, toutes brûlées.
- Comme l'accès au village de
Lytton est toujours interdit,
Geneviève et sa famille ont
décidé de prendre la route.
La jeune femme originaire
de Bonaventure, en Gaspésie,
a besoin de retrouver les siens.
- Paqueter nos affaires,
faire le tour jusqu'à Hope,
puis partir pour la Gaspésie,
parce qu'on en a vraiment
besoin, puis on a besoin
de voir notre famille
puis d'être loin des feux,
puis t'sais, c'est quand même
stressant encore.
- Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, B